[Music]
the Jungle Book was the less anime film
those made while Disney was alive which
is interesting because the two films
that would follow would steal such an
unbelievable amount of animation from it
and as Disney films go this is another
one that I probably just plays in the
okay category personally I'm not a huge
fan of the more sketchy style of Disney
Animation at least not around this time
period then we sort of look like pencil
sketches that were painted over and
never quite looks finished to me if
you're a fan of great it just doesn't do
much for me but tea syrup so how's the
story well based on Rui our Kipling's
bug though very loosely it follows the
story of a little boy or man cub as
animals call him named Mowgli he's
raised by a pack of wolves but suddenly
his life is in danger when the evil
tiger Shere Khan is coming to town Shere
Khan hates man and the Wolves know he'll
end up ripping into shreds if he ever
finds him Philip Anthony Bagheera takes
Mowgli to the man village the only
problem is locally doesn't want to go he
wants to stay in the jungle and tries
every chance he can to get away while on
the way he comes across a friendly bear
named Baloo a marching elephant army a
crazy ape named King Louie and a
hypnotizing snake named kah well let's
talk about the good stuff the best thing
in this movie is sheer Kon
he's just a great villain he actually
reminds me a lot of Maleficent there's
not really much motivation to him but
just a style and class he has is so
friggin awesome
he's so confident in what a badass he is
that it really does actually come off
pretty intimidating he just has nothing
to fear
the snake Cobb I'm not a main villain
who's also pretty cool some of the best
parts of the movie are just all the
jokes they can make with how long he is
don't take that the wrong way aside from
that the boy is okay the other
characters are okay the songs are you
guessed it okay actually I take it back
the very last song the girl sings while
giving the water actually I think is a
very nice tune
I don't like to hear a different updated
version of it because it actually has a
very soothing melody but aside from that
nothing really stands out too much for
me about this jungle book which is a
shame because the original book is not
only much darker but it's much more
interesting the way the animal world
views the human world is actually sort
of a fascinating
commentary the characters are more
developed too and it follows Mowgli
through sort of a coming-of-age story
which is really a shame because I think
Disney could do the story great Chuck
Jones in a version that was much closer
to the book in a half hour
I found that infinitely more fascinating
than this film but as is there's nothing
really bad about the jungle book except
like I said not following the book that
closely but that's its own separate
thing it works out fine it's a very
basic kids film
what-you-see-is-what-you-get it kept me
entertained as a little kid and I'm sure
you'll keep your kids entertained as
well a few creative scenes and one or
two characters definitely make it worth
a watch
[Music]
you